willkommen in meiner Vorratskammer ich
bin Marie und ich baue das Obst und
Gemüse für meine Familie fast komplett
selber an und da ist es natürlich super
wichtig dass man den Überfluss den man
im Sommer hat für den Winter haltbar
macht deswegen zeige ich euch jetzt mal
was ich hier für Schätzchen angekocht
fermentiert getrocknet eingelagert habe
fangen wir mal hier oben an hier habe
ich ganz viel Apfelmus eingekocht
Apfelmus einzukochen ist super aufwendig
deswegen bin ich sehr sehr stolz dass
ich hier so viel stehen habe die habe
ich auch ein paar Apfelstücke eingekocht
dann auch so ein paar Variationen wie
zum Beispiel hier Apfel Quittenmus und
hier habe ich noch was mit Mirabellen
eingekocht dann gehen wir weiter zu
unseren Zimt Pflaumen das ist auch so
ein absolutes Must-Have ich habe so fünf
Sachen die ich auf jeden Fall jedes Jahr
haltbar machen muss sonst bin ich total
unglücklich und Apfelmus und zimpflaumen
gehören auf jeden Fall dazu zimpflaumen
einzukochen ist auch super super einfach
ich verlinke euch gerne in den Rezept
unten in der Videobeschreibung dazu habe
ich nämlich auch schon mal ein Video
gemacht dann machen wir weiter mit hier
Zucchini Paprika Auberginen Gemüse das
habe ich im druckeinkochtopf haltbar
gemacht säurearme Lebensmittel sollte
man nämlich immer bei Temperaturen von
um die 120 Grad je nachdem wie lange man
das einkocht haltbar machen um
Botulismus auszuschließen hier habe ich
saure Gurken eingekocht aber nicht
klassisch so wie man es normal macht
sondern in Scheiben geschnitten das
funktioniert auch sehr gut mit
Salatgurken ich hatte letztes Jahr super
viele Salatgurken da habe ich auch noch
diese Gläser von übrig weil da jetzt
Essig zugefügt ist muss man das nicht im
Druck Einkochtopf haltbar machen sondern
das geht auch in einem normalen Kochtopf
oder einem ganz normalen Einkochtopf
hier haben wir noch mehr saure Gurken
die sind ganz klassisch einfach in
Stücken eingekocht ihr seht ihr gerade
hier habe ich noch ein kleiner besondere
Variation ich bau nämlich auf
mexikanische Minigurken an wenn man nur
ein zwei Minigolfen Pflanzen hat dann
erntet man meist schon viel mehr als man
einfach so frisch essen und dann kommen
wir jetzt zu meiner Marmelade Fraktion
ja habe ich z.B ganz viel Pflaumenmus
haltbar gemacht das macht wirklich
unglaublich viel Spaß weil die ganze
Wohnung so arg nach Weihnachten duftet
wenn man das macht und ich esse das auch
in rauen Mengen gerade im Moment ich
mache gerade eine Challenge wo ich 100
Tage nur das erste was ich selber
angebaut oder aus der Natur gesammelt
habe da ist es natürlich sehr sehr cool
dass ich jetzt so eine volle
Vorratskammer habe und ich mache überall
Pflaumenmus dran weil das einfach so gut
zu einem passt und ich sonst sehr wenig
Soßen habe die ich selber aus nur selbst
erzeugten Lebensmitteln herstellen kann
und dann habe ich hierher gefunden
Marmelade das ist schon so ein kleiner
Schatz von mir weil jeder der selber
schon nachher geboten Marmelade
hergestellt hat und die ganzen Kerne und
die ganzen Haare aus dem Fruchtfleisch
entfernt hat der weiß wie viel Arbeit in
so einem kleinen Gläschen steckt
deswegen werden die auch nur ein ganz
besonderen Tagen aufgemacht dann habe
ich hier noch süß kirschenmarmelade
Erdbeermarmelade Apfel Butter das kennen
nur sehr wenig Leute in Deutschland ab
für Butter mache ich immer wenn ich auch
Apfelmus herstelle und dann koche ich
das einfach viel dicker ein packen noch
Zucker und Gewürze rein also auch so
Zimt und wie heißt das Garam Masala dann
lässt man das einfach stundenlang vor
sich hin blubbern wird ständig um und
dann hat man irgendwann dieses goldene
unglaublich leckere Zeug das nehmen wir
als Brotaufstrich aber in letzter zeit
esse ich das eben auch einfach ganz
gerne mal zu Kartoffeln und hier habe
ich noch eine stinknormale
Johannisbeermarmelade dann kommen wir
hier in die
tomatensoßen Abteilung da mache ich
meistens immer das gleiche Rezept
verlinke ich euch auch gerne unter dem
Video das ist auch ein Klassiker der
jedes Jahr ins Regal wandern muss ich
habe übrigens einen Onlinekurs mit dem
ganzen wissen wie man was einkocht wie
man was trocknet wie man was fermentiert
und natürlich auch allen Rezepten ihr
könnt euch gerne dafür anmelden wenn ihr
wollt der Link ist unten in der
Videobeschreibung seht hier oben in der
Ecke ich würde mich super an freuen wenn
ihr mit dabei seid wir haben aber hier
oben auch noch ein paar Sachen einmal
Kürbisse leider auch gar nicht mehr so
viele da kommen noch zwei Kürbisse dazu
ich glaube viel mehr ist es dieses Jahr
gar nicht geworden und hier habe ich
meine große Hoffnung für die 100 Tage
Selbstversorger Challenge das einzige
Getreide das mir in dieser Zeit zur
Verfügung steht ist der Mais den ich
angebaut habe das ist kein Zuckermais
sondern hart meist die man für Polenta
nehmen kann ich habe auch schon Brot
daraus gebacken aber man sieht das ist
halt echt gar nicht so viel genau den
werde ich mir gut einteilen machen wir
mit der zweiten Hälfte weiter hier habe
ich mir so einen tollen Flaschenhalter
besorgt und dachte mir da kann ich
meinen ganzen Sirup reinlegen alles ist
schön geordnet aber es funktioniert
überhaupt nicht weil die ganzen Flaschen
in denen ich bisher Sachen eingekauft
habe viel zu schmal sind die fallen
einfach durch deswegen habe ich ja so
ein paar Platzhalter leere Flaschen rein
gemacht damit ich weiß wenn ich noch mal
irgendwas Flaschen eingekauft dann kommt
es in die Flaschen und dann kann ich das
in Zukunft ganz toll da alles auf
stapeln dann haben wir hier noch ein
paar Gläser die zu hoch sind um hier in
meine unteren Regale zu passen das wird
noch mal zwei Gläser mit zimpflaumen ein
großes Apfelmus wir werden mal besucht
da ist oder so hier stehen und paar
Zwiebeln rum aber die kommen eigentlich
noch hier unten das zeige ich euch auch
gleich was hier unten alles noch lagert
hier habe ich Essig hergestellt das rote
ist zum Beispiel erdbeeressig man kann
Essig so leicht aus obstresten
herstellen man kann quasi aus jedem Obst
Essig herstellen und das macht
wahnsinnig viel Spaß weil es so einfach
ist und man einfach seine eigenen Essig
hat und das auch twenty zu verschenken
in der schönen Flasche abgefüllt oder so
wir haben wir Schmalz das gehört
eigentlich auch nach da unten ein Kürbis
liegt hier noch rum das sind Süßkirschen
die ich eingekocht habe hier haben wir
Rotkraut noch ein paar Gläser das ist
ein bärenkompott davon esse ich jeden
Moment auch sehr viel zum Beispiel zum
Frühstück hier sind noch ein paar Zimt
Pflaumen weil die Reihe hier noch ein
bisschen weiter ging das sind Bohnen
Bohnen sind wieder so eine Sache die
sollte man unter Druck einkochen und
wenn ihr das nicht gemacht habt schmeißt
eure Vorräte auf keinen Fall weg ihr
könnt die vor dem Essen einfach für 15
Minuten sprudeln aufkochen dann sind
alle Gifte die eventuell in dem Glas
entstanden sein könnten denaturiert und
ihr könnt das Ganze trotzdem bedenkenlos
weiterhin essen ansonsten könnt ihr auch
immer Essig hinzugeben wenn ihr Gemüse
einkocht die von selbst nicht genug seid
enthalten wie ich zum Beispiel bei
diesem rote Beete Gläsern hier gemacht
habe da hatte ich meine riesengroße rote
Beete Ernte im Garten und habe quasi
alles in Essig eingekocht und jetzt
stehe ich hier mit der ganzen Roten
Beete und ich mag fermentierte rote
Beete eigentlich immer viel lieber als
in Essig eingekochte mal gucken ob die
Challenge so hart wird dass ich die auch
noch komplett auf esse wir werden sehen
was glaubt ihr denn wie weit komme ich
mit dem Vorrat also viele Leute sehen
das und denken warum was hast du denn
hier alles aber ich meine so ein Glas
Kirschen macht halt nicht unbedingt satt
ne also es hat auch nicht viele Kalorien
genauso wenig wie sinnpflaumen
vielleicht die Bohnen machen noch am
ehesten satt aber das meiste ist halt
eher eine Beilage als man wirkliches
Gericht ich koche aber auch oft mal
Suppe ein oder hier unten habe ich zum
Beispiel Gulasch eingekocht was man dann
einfach nur aufmachen muss und dann hat
man eine fertiges Gericht das ist schon
sehr toll hier habe ich noch Erbsen und
Möhren zwei Gläschen dahinter ist
Ziegenfleisch hier habe ich ganz viel
Zucchini eingekocht die habe ich in
Essig und Öl sauer eingekocht aber das
ist in dem Fall total lecker weil das so
ein bisschen nach Antipasti schmeckt ja
wenn noch mehr Kirschen ich weiß nicht
warum ich zu doof war die irgendwie alle
zusammen zu stellen und hier ist eben
rehgulasch hier ist Hirschgulasch
dahinter habe ich auch noch Knochenbrühe
also wenn wir ein Tier essen dann
verarbeiten wir immer alles weil ich
finde das hat auch irgendwie was mit
Ehrfurcht zu tun und wenn du ihn ein
Tier Essen und das dafür dann will ich
auch bis auf den letzten fixe alles an
den Tier verarbeiten deswegen habe ich
zum Beispiel auch hier ganz viel Schmalz
hergestellt sowohl aus Ziege als auch
Reh und Hirsch das hilft mir jetzt auch
in der Challenge enorm weiter weil ich
ja selber gar kein Fett anbauen kann im
Garten bzw habe ich das bisher halt noch
nie gemacht dann habe ich hier ein Glas
Honig das habe ich mal gegen Tomaten und
anderes Gemüse eingetauscht mit unseren
Nachbarn ich brauche aber für die
Challenge auf jeden Fall noch mehr Honig
deswegen werde ich da auf jeden Fall
noch mehr eintauschen und das hier ist
Sauerkraut hier habe ich noch
tortenfleisch einmal Reh Trockenfleisch
und dann auch welches vom Hirsch das ist
ganz praktisch wenn man mal unterwegs
ist inzwischen durch einen kleinen Snack
will hier habe ich noch was zum snacken
das ist fruchtleder das rollig immer so
in den Backpapier Schnipseln ein weil
man sonst okaybrige Finger bekommt das
kann man auch wunderbar mitnehmen und
das einfach mal zwischendurch zu essen
wenn ich dazu mein ganze sehr gerne
Bescheid hier habe ich einen
Birkenporling der ist gut für die
damengesundheit Hallimasch haben wir
getrocknet hier sind Steinpilze da habe
ich ja Parasole getrocknet hat zwar
nicht viel Nährwert aber es ist total
schön damals irgendwie Gerichte ja zu
würzen und das macht es einfach ja das
macht das Leben schöner und Pilze
sammeln macht so viel Spaß das hätte ich
irgendwie gar nicht erwartet ich dachte
es wäre so nur furchterregend und dass
ich nicht das sowieso gar nicht traue
weil ich mich so schlecht auskenne aber
jetzt haben wir uns mal seit ein paar
Wochen näher damit beschäftigt und es
macht einfach wirklich wirklich viel
Spaß und dann habe ich hier eine andere
große Hoffnung für meine Challenge das
sind nämlich ganz viele Nüsse ähm einmal
Haselnüsse ich habe drüben auch noch
Walnüsse die ich noch nicht sauber
gemacht habe die haben noch diese
schwarze Schale und so dran aber die
hier habe ich mal mit einem
kurbelnussknacker geknackt das ist
wirklich wenn man viele Nüsse erntet und
viele Nüsse ist eine super Investition
weil eigentlich alle Nüsse von
handknacken muss dann habe ich hier
Chilis ich habe auch noch hier oben so
einen chilisopf den ich mal geflochten
habe aber der ist so schön dass ich
lieber erstmal die Chilis im Glas
aufbrauche bevor ich hier irgendwas
Abrufe ja ihr seht schon ich werde
wahrscheinlich nie wieder in meinem
Leben Chilis anbauen müssen hier ist
noch was cooles das ist Popcorn Mais ich
habe jetzt während der Challenge auch
schon viel Popcorn gegessen dass ja
hatte ich erst gar nicht auf dem Schirm
aber das ist super cool sich sein
eigenes salziges Popcorn zu machen dann
haben wir hier meine ganzen Fermente das
hier ist z.B Mangold den ich fermentiert
habe den füllt man in die Flaschen wenn
er noch bunt ist und dann verliert er
leider nach und nach seine Farbe aber er
ist trotzdem super lecker das ist ein
Ferment was auch nicht so streng
schmeckt also wenn euch Sauerkraut zu
krass ist dann probiert auf jeden Fall
mal Mangold aus ich habe hier noch ein
Wurzelgemüse fermentiert Bohnen sind
auch super lecker wenn man die
fermentierte das ist so hier ist
Blumenkohl den ich fermentiert habe wir
haben noch Radieschen Paprika auf jeden
Fall jede Menge Fermente die hier in
dieser Kiste Lagern falls was überläuft
wird nämlich nicht mein ganzes Regal
versaut dann habe ich hier noch Zwiebeln
ich habe noch viel mehr Zwiebeln
angebaut aber das allermeiste ist in den
Gläsern von den Sachen die ich schon
eingekocht habe gerade bei der
Tomatensoße hier bei den Zucchini da
geht immer richtig viel drauf so dass
ich gar nicht mehr so viele Fische oder
ja sag mir eingelagert habe und hier
habe ich Knoblauch aus dem Garten
das wird wahrscheinlich auch noch eine
ganze Weile reichen und dann zeige ich
euch noch mal was hier im nachbarschrank
ist man muss ja auch irgendwo einen Ort
haben an dem man die ganzen Einkauf
Gläser lagert hier habe ich auf jeden
Fall noch ein paar unbenutzte Gläser
hier habe ich alles was ich zur
Fleischverarbeitung und zum Räuchern
brauche Zubehör Sachen von meinem
Einkochtopf habe ich hier in diesem
Kisten z.B die Gummiringe die ich zum
brauche hier sind die ganzen Glasdeckel
drin und
in der anderen Kiste sind Schraubdeckel
das ist ein fermentiergewicht auf sehr
praktisch damit mache ich die Körner von
den Maiskolben ab das ist ein uraltes
Gerät dass ich gebraucht gefunden habe
und das ist so cool da fliegen an der
Seite die Kolben raus unten fallen die
Körner raus und das macht wahnsinnig
Spaß damit meiste verarbeiten ich sollte
eigentlich viel mehr Mais anbauen
alleine damit ich dieses Gerät hier mehr
benutzen kann hier unten habe ich zwei
Kisten stehen um leere Gläser zu lagern
das ist wenn man viel einkocht und viel
Eingekochtes ist super super praktisch
für die irgendeinen Ort zu haben weil
die sich sonst überall Türmen hier habe
ich Schraubgläser und hier weggläser
oder Messengers und hier habe ich noch
einen Schrank für gekaufte Lebensmittel
die werde ich natürlich während der
Challenge nicht essen aber zum Beispiel
mein Sohn und mein Freund hier habe ich
noch mehr Honig wird auch so gerne mich
selber machen aber ich habe eine
bienenallergie vielleicht fängt mein
Freund nächstes Jahr damit an hier
dieses Festo liegt mein Sohn total
deswegen kaufen wir das auch zu und das
hier ist ein Sauerteig Backup wenn ihr
mit Sauerteig backt dann kennt ihr das
bestimmt dass ihr mal aus Versehen Salz
in den Vorteil gemacht habt und dann
einen neuen ansetzen müsst und für
solche Fälle ist es super praktisch
dieses Backup zu machen und dafür
einfach mal auf dem Backpapier so eine
dünne Schicht Vorteig auszustreichen die
trockenen zu lassen und dann in dem Glas
zu lagern das hier sind Bohnen die ich
gekauft und dann eingekocht habe
deswegen habe ich sie ja mal zur Seite
geräumt weil ich ja die selber
angebauten Sachen jetzt nur nach esse
das ist aber auch eine super praktische
Sache weil wenn man trocken Bohnen
kochen will dann muss man dir immer
super lange einweichen und ist nicht so
spontan mit dem Kochen deswegen mache
ich das ganz gerne dass ich einfach mal
ein paar Bohnen so einkochen habe ich
die ganz schnell parat und dann zeige
ich euch noch meine Gefriertruhe da habe
ich erstmal ein großes Hirschfeld drin
dass wir noch nicht ge
ansonsten ist hier ganz viel Gemüse noch
drin obwohl ich viel lieber auf
fermentiere einfache und Böse als
einzufrieren aber hier habe ich z.B blau
Boden und Brokkoli Rosenkohl habe ich
hier Spinat hier ist noch
petersilie ist das glaube ich ja auch
schlau das mal zum Schluss jetzt habe
ich ganz viel Fleisch z.B vom Hirsch ich
habe noch ich glaube vier Forellen die
mein Sohn gefangen hat mit zwei Rehe
sind ja auch noch drin und dann haben
wir hier so eine kleine
extraabteilung da ist z.B Hundefutter
drin also z.B die Beine von den Tieren
bei der wie gesagt versuchen das ganze
Tier zu verwerten das hier ist das Hirn
mit dem wir dann später das Fell Gerben
aber einfrieren ist von allen haltbar
mach Methoden finde ich diejenigen die
ich am wenigsten mag weil mein Leben so
viel Strom braucht um das Ganze dann zu
lagern aber es ist natürlich praktisch
wenn man schnell viel verarbeiten will
ich verlinke euch da drüben die Playlist
zu meiner 100 Tage Selbstversorger
Challenge wenn ihr verfolgen wollt wie
es mir so ergeht dann geht raus und
macht die Welt ein bisschen grüner und
wir sehen uns im nächsten Video wieder
macht's gut tschüss
und hier habe ich meine
[Musik]